messieurs bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france alors emmanuel macron a
donc pris la parole ce soir devant les
français pour revenir sur la situation
en afghanistan des forces spéciales
françaises vont être envoyés dans les
prochaines heures pour assurer la pâte
le rapatriement des ressortissants
français le chef de l'état a notamment
dit vouloir protéger les arguments qui
ont hanté des la france claude
blanchemaison il était important qu
emmanuel macron s'exprime rapidement
après la prise de pouvoir des talibans
oui je crois qu'il voulait marquer qu'il
s'agissait bien là d'un tournant
historique
absolument décisive déterminant il ya 20
ans la coalition menée par les
américains visez daher indiqué les bases
du terrorisme international qui avait
établi la la la la non pas en fait en
afghanistan et ce travail a été fait
d'ailleurs il a rappelé que la france
avait pris sa part puisque les
militaires français sont intervenus
jusqu en 2013 que trois présidents de la
république successifs on tue à prendre
des décisions à ce sujet que lorsque
stupide laden ben laden a été éliminé
eh bien il était peut-être temps de
réduire le volume de cette intervention
militaire c'est en tout cas ce qui a été
fait pour la partie française et puis
ensuite en 2013 de cesser cette
intervention militaire quillan le fonds
avait plus de raison d'être mais en
poursuivant un certain nombre d'actions
à caractère civil il a bien marqué le le
le départ entre l'action qui visait à
éliminer ses bases du terrorisme
international et que mme hakima temps va
se continuer par des moyens
diplomatiques au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu dès ce soir avec les autres
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité et d'autre part le régime en
cours le régime qui est qui qui a qu'à
court qui a cours en afghanistan et à
cet égard effectivement il n'a pas dit
qu'il était inéluctable évidemment que
les que les talibans reviennent au
pouvoir mais il a accepté cette
situation
en tout en disant que naturellement la
france resterait très attentive au sort
qui serait fait aux femmes au sort qui
serait fait aux journalistes au sort qui
serait fait au aux professeurs et par
conséquent au respect des droits de
l'homme et qu'elle que la france
continuera par son action diplomatique
sur place a aidé la société civile
également à aider les ong je rappelle
d'ailleurs que acte aides et médecins
sans frontières ont été autorisées ces
jours ci à continuer leur action par les
autorités afghanes que par ailleurs il y
a il y a à kaboul un hôpital que les
argots pris pour habitude d'appeler
l'hôpital français où on a formé un
certain nombre de chirurgiens notamment
dans la chirurgie du coeur des hommes et
des femmes et que bien entendu ceci peut
continuer à fonctionner alors j'avance
pierre claude blanchou faisons nous le
rappelait le chef de l'état est donc
revenu sur l'intervention militaire en
afghanistan
il a dit que cette opération cette
intervention militaire ne sera pas vaine
à l'avenir et qu'elle n'a pas été fait
pour rien et puis quand on voit les
images de ces dernières heures va
peut-être qu'on peut avoir du mal à le
croire
l'intervention militaire aujourd'hui
elle a encore des effets en afghanistan
elle a eu des effets pendant 20 ans elle
a permis de créer un pays qui est
complètement bios pas peut-être
complètement mais substantiellement
différent de ce qu'il était en 1996 en
1996 ou n'aviez certainement pas une
ville telle que kaboul les maintenant à
la fois dans le nombre de sa population
dans son profil de population et dans
son appel à la liberté liberté de pensée
liberté du travail liberté d'éducation
pour les jeunes femmes liberté du
travail pour ces mêmes jeunes femmes
donc il y a vraiment un bouillonnement à
kaboul qui se traduit effectivement part
à la peur et donc le désir pour les
kaboulis de pouvoir quitter leur pays
parce que là désengagement des taliban à
moyen terme ne sont pas tout à fait
évident donc il y a eu la capacité la
possibilité la réalité pour la présence
occidentale
il ya plus de 30 pays finalement qui ont
été impliqués dans cette situation à qui
on donnait une empreinte et qui ont créé
une organiste en différent de ce qu'il
était en 1996 et les talibans devront
tenir compte alors claude blanche maison
joe biden lui doit s'adresser dans la
soirée aux américains est il est sous le
feu des critiques 1 par son silence
jusque là mais aussi montré du doigt
pour n'avoir rien vu venir comme la
france d'ailleurs comme le reste de la
communauté internationale comment est ce
que on peut comprendre qu'un tel
scénario n'est pas été envisagée
bon c'est quand même son prédécesseur à
donald trump qui a négocié en février
2020 le retrait des troupes américaines
avec les talibans et qui a obtenu
d'ailleurs d'une certaine manière que
pendant les opérations de retrait il n'y
ait pas d'attentats contre les troupes
américaines
en revanche il n'a obtenu que la
négociation se déroule entre les
talibans et le gouvernement de kaboul
pour aboutir à une solution politique à
une nouvelle formule politique donc joe
biden va dire de toute façon la décision
de retrait avait été prise je les
confirme et elle avait été prise pour le
1er mai je les retarder au début du mois
de septembre aurait été au 31 août mais
à quoi servirait-il de rester plus
longtemps puisque l'objectif essentiel
de
la mission a été remplie
les terroristes ont été éradiqués les
bases terroristes n'existe plus et comme
l'a dit tout à l'heure monsieur vespière
le société a évolué et notamment elle a
évolué aussi pour des raisons
démographiques parce qu'on afghanistan
la moitié de la population a moins de 20
ans et par conséquent effectivement les
talibans ne se trouve plus dans la même
situation que ceux qui dirigeaient le
pays vingt ans auparavant alors
effectivement ce que on peut reprocher
probablement avec quelques raison à
l'administration américaine c'est la
manière dont ce retrait est effectué
c'est à dire sans véritable concertation
avec les autorités afghanes avec le
gouvernement afghane avec les alliés et
dans des conditions relativement
précipité mais est ce qu'il était
possible de faire autrement ça n'est pas
absolument sûr on savait qu'à partir du
1er mai les les talibans commencerait à
manifester par parra par les armes par
des attentats le fait que la la limite
du 1er mai n'avait pas été respectée
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'ils ont fait les
opérations ont commencé on peut partir
du début du mois de mai et il était sans
doute difficile pour l'administration
américaine
d'empêcher l'application de cette
décision de retrait qui avait été prise
d'autant plus que encore une fois la
perpétuation de la présence américaine
n'avait pas de raison d'être même si le
département de la défense aux états unis
penser que peut-être les états unis
étaient là pour l'éternité geagea un
vestiaire l'administration américaine
elle aurait pu faire autrement justement
l'administration américaine elle n'était
pas là pour l'éternité parce que depuis
le search des opérations militaires
entrepris par barack obama donc en en
2009-2010 à les états unis avaient
mobilisé jusqu'à cent mille hommes en
afghanistan et voyant que effectivement
ce mouvement ne correspondait pas à
l'amélioration de la situation barack
obama a réduit de 20 mille hommes par an
donc en 2012 2013 il a laissé à son
successeur donald trump une force d'à
peu près trente mille hommes qui a été
continuellement réduit jusqu'à aux 2500
soldats du mois de décembre donc voyez
vous il ya eu un continuum et
pratiquement fait prendre une règle et
un crayon et dire eh bien voilà on va
arriver au point zéro a au cours de
l'année 2000 21 1 comme il était prévu
par les accords de doha donc signé en
février 2020 dont vous voyez vous
février 2000 20 août 2021 et bien tout
cela a été scrupuleusement suivi il y
avait effectivement une volonté du
département d'état et du pentagone de se
retirer d'afghanistan et cela a été fait
méticuleusement depuis dix ans alors
cette dernière question messieurs alors
on a d'un côté un l'onu qui a appelé le
monde à lutter contre le terrorisme et
puis on a de l'autre la chine ou la
russie qui ont dit à préférer la
diplomatie et la négociation quels
changements géopolitiques dans les jours
dans les mois à venir dans la région
selon vous claude blanchemaison
les chine la russie et l'iran sont dans
une situation très particulière est à
dire que géographiquement ce sont des
pays très proche de l'afghanistan et qui
ont beaucoup de chose à craindre de d'un
retour offensif les talibans c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs les chinois le
ministre des affaires étrangères chinois
a reçu de façon tout à fait
solennel le
le représentant le numéro deux des
taliban pour l'écouter et l'entendre
dire que les talibans ne chercherait à
aucun cas en aucun cas à gêner la chine
à offrir des abris ouigours vous à
d'éventuels
rebelles ouigours comme cela avait été
le cas lorsque les taliban étaient au
pouvoir et la chine voit en effet là une
opportunité si les taliban tienne parole
de développer peut-être ces routes de la
soie qui joue un rôle déjà tellement
d'importants acquis ce temps vers
l'afghanistan la russie elle a une tâche
très importante elle doit sécuriser la
frontière du tadjikistan et
l'ouzbékistan frontière extrêmement
poreuse et commencer la russie a une
division et une base au tadjikistan et a
joué un rôle très important dans la
formation des gardes frontières tadjik
car son tir tadjik qui ne font
apparemment pas toujours leur travail de
façon presque close puisque des
quantités très importantes de drogue
transitent par cette frontière et vont
ensuite se répandre
en russie et derrière en europe donc là
la russie c'est qu'elle doit garder
cette frontière est par conséquent pour
cela parle aux talibans et considère
qu'elle peut me traiter avec les
talibans l'iran craint pour les azhari
puisque ce sont des sites alors que les
talibans sont des sunnites est que dans
le passé les azhari on était très mal
traité mais j'allais dire que puisque
vous parlez de la des changements
géopolitiques
la france va rester va rester à kaboul
les sa mission diplomatique ne va pas se
retirer d'ailleurs le président de la
république n'a pas parlé ce soir il a
bien fait ni de reconnaissance des
talibans n'ont ni de rupture des
relations diplomatiques
et il n'y a pas de raison de reconnaître
les talibans il n'y a pas de raison non
plus de rompre les relations
diplomatiques nous avons les relations
diplomatique avec un pays ce pays change
de gouvernement change de régime
probablement et bien les relations
diplomatiques de moeurs est en effet
comme je le dis tout à l'heure la france
estime karl a des responsabilités
importantes vis-à-vis de la population
civile importante vis-à-vis des ong
françaises qui travaillent en
afghanistan est important d vis-à-vis
aussi d'un certain nombre de gens qui
autrefois ont été dans des lycées où ils
ont appris le français gérard aspirine
oise quelques secondes pour conclure le
chef de l'état français qui appelait
aussi à une coopération russie europe
américain c'est quelque chose
d'envisageable à l'avenir
dira écoutez effectivement y'a pus
lequel seconde parce que les
ambassadeurs soit parfois quelques peu
volumineux donc il y a une volonté de
changer considérablement la situation
nous avons eu une situation mondiale en
afghanistan avec l'intervention de plus
d'une trentaine de pays à incluant tous
les membres de l'otan vous avez eu après
simplement des états unis et quelques
pays donc une situation internationale
maintenant la rga nice temps et dans le
cadre d'une situation régionale
effectivement avec les voisins et les
presque voisin l'inde a eu un rôle très
important en demandant aux talibans de
ne pas avoir de d'après d'opérations
sanglantes dans la prise du pouvoir car
une opération sanglante à mener à une
guerre civile une guerre civile en
afghanistan ni lui l'iran n'en voulait
où les problèmes de réfugiés ni'lin n'en
voulait avec le cachemire ni la russie
n'en voulait avec donc sa population
musulmane donc maintenant ça va être aux
arçons et aux acteurs régionaux de se
confronter et de canaliser la situation
de l'afghanistan merci à tous les jeunes
merci à vous que deux manches maison
expert en relations internationales
merci roue gérard vespière fondateur du
site d'analysé le monde décrypté
directeur de recherche à la fondation
d'études pour le moyen-orient